we're gonna turn to the Middle East now
Gaza and Israel are facing their worst
violence in years amid escalating
attacks by Israeli and Hamas forces
hundreds of rockets were launched
overnight it's both sides exchanged fire
the deadly violence follows and
apparently botched Israeli military
mission in Gaza over the weekend Charlie
d'Agata is in the Israeli city of
Ashkelon near the Gaza border Charlie
good morning good morning what's just
some of the damage left behind after
waves of attacks here in Ashkelon last
night at Hamas where militant rocket
slammed into this house and blew a hole
in the wall miraculously everybody here
survived Ashkelon is very close to gaza
which within range of militant rockets
it's also where a rocket hit an
apartment and killed a man inside now
here's the scene last night the Israeli
military says some 400 rockets were
fired into Israel the famed Iron Dome
defense system was able to intercept
more than a hundred now this morning
Palestinians in Gaza awoke to widespread
destruction from Israeli air strikes and
tank fire now the Israeli military says
the targets included a Hamas TV and
radio station and the group's alleged
headquarters now both sides have been
brought back to the brink of war after
that alleged botched commando mission
that left seven Hamas militants and one
Israeli lieutenant-colonel dead now this
morning Hamas threatened to extend its
reach to include further cities in
what's already become the worst fighting
this country has seen since the 2014
Gaza war Nora
alright Charlie d'Agata in Israel thank
you